es geht darum dass ich nach einer
scheidung in den finanziellen in ein
finanzielles chaos geflogen bin hat nun
wieder einen job gefunden habe mich da
herausgeholt
mit dem mit der einschränkung dass sich
private insolvenz anmelden musste und
alles läuft eigentlich gut ist auch die
tatsache dass ich jetzt mal wieder kein
auto habe ich aber ohne auto mein dorf
nicht ausführen kann
ich weiß gar nicht wie das jetzt ist ob
ich jetzt nur noch eins finanzieren kann
ja ich bräuchte irgendwie rat hilfe was
kann ich machen
vielleicht vielleicht ist das der
strohhalm den ich suche
vielen dank und auf wiedersehen
sehr viele zuschauer stellen und solche
fragen die sind dann unverschuldet in
eine privatinsolvenz geraten und das hat
natürlich noch nach da gibt es halt um
negative schufa einträge und die
behindern dann möglicherweise das
nächste kreditgeschäft was kann dieser
zuschauer denn jetzt tun
also wir haben erstmal schonvermögen
auch innerhalb von insolvenzverfahren
das heißt alles was sozusagen zum shop
auch erforderlich ist oder liegt ja dem
schonvermögen bis zu bestimmten grenzen
natürlich und da müsste man im
einzelfall vielleicht mal gucken was da
geht und was nicht dann weiß ich auch
ganz interessant finde es gibt durchaus
auch möglichkeiten auch fahrzeuge mit zu
finanzieren sich seitens des jobcenters
denn wenn ein beispielsweise ein
fahrzeug unbedingt erforderlich ist um
um einen job zu bekommen sei es auch der
führerschein beispielsweise und sogar
fahrzeuge da gibt es sogar so ein
gutscheinsystem in bestimmten fällen
dass man also zu 1 mit führerschein
bezahlt bekommt um beispielsweise fahrer
tätigkeiten zu machen oder im lkw
bereich zu arbeiten und sogar das
fahrzeug in bestimmten fällen und dann
müsste man vielleicht mal bei der
örtlichen jobcenter man darf fragen
seinen fall schildern
seine vision schildern was will ich
damit machen mit dem fahrzeug mit dem
führerschein und eben dann versuchen
dann eine möglichkeit zu finden